this video is brought to you by Samsung
gear VR powered by oculus virtual
reality anywhere for ninety-nine dollars
hey guys my name is Jess and you are
watching the last games but needs
episode of the whole year thanks for
doing that here's what mattered in
gaming this week
develop this on battlefield 5 has begun
according to a member the dev team four
star wars battlefront development
director Dan mandolin confirmed that
some of the battlefront team is
migrating over to work on the next game
in the Battlefield franchise he tweeted
now that we've shipped battlefront and a
part of the team continues to work on it
I am moving on to another project the
next battlefield expected to be called
battlefield 5 the next game in the
series is scheduled for release in 2016
and dices said the game will return to
its military roots dinosaur rhythmic a
game Ark survival evolved is getting to
play a local split screen on Xbox one
and the big deal to a lot of it
developer studio wild card announced the
news earlier this week before the games
Xbox release unfortunately although the
game is now out split screen isn't ready
just yet and will be added in an update
early next year the feature is currently
exclusive to the xbox one version
creative director and co-founder jesse
raptor told GameSpot many developers are
abandoning switch screen local play but
we couldn't stomach that for arc look
forward to working together to survive
the environment change its inhabitants
and unravel the mysteries of the island
all from the same cap
this week Activision added new
microtransactions to destiny and call of
duty black ops 3 the latter of which now
has cold GD points the game's black
market store now has a bunch of new
items you can buy through supply drops
on ps4 xbox one and pc the items are
available for the multiplayer and
zombies modes and include weapons
outfits taunts camos and cosmetic
attachments while you can obtain the
items through traditional play you can
also pick them up to call the GD points
which cost real worlds dollars 200 card
points will cost you two dollars while
5000 will run you forty dollars the
final Nintendo Direct dedicated to super
smash brothers on Wii U and greedy ass
was held this week and here's what
you'll want to know some maps a brand
new Fire Emblem character has joined the
ranks of the smash brawlers Canterbury
of next year you'll be able to strike as
Corrin playable is both male and female
dlc character final fantasy 7 cloud is
available to purchase in smash right now
as well as the newest a stage Nintendo
also revealed that the final DLC
characters the smash will be Bayonetta
and there's a stack of new costume DLC
on its way as well as new an EVO finally
this week it was confirmed that had a
Okajima has formed his own independent
studio and it will be working with Sony
on their first game gladdimir confirmed
that his employment contract with konami
has been terminated and his new studio
also called Kojima Productions will be
creating a ps4 console exclusive cousin
Rosa said he is thrilled to embark on
creating a new franchise we have no
extra information about the plant new
title as yet but it has been confirmed
that the game will come to PC after
debuting on ps4 let me know down in the
comments what you cared about this week
and if you're keen for the newly
announced smash characters this week on
site we continue our countdown of our
best 25 games of the whole year there's
detox the future via on in two minutes
and I tell you about the coolest-looking
the ass of water games on the disk that
is it for GS means this year thanks so
much for tuning in and for your support
we do hope you have a great holiday
break and I'll see you again in January